la sncf encore dans l'un des dépôts les
plus dures de ce conflit au mans pour la
première fois ce matin au cours d'un
vote une trentaine de cheminots se sont
prononcés pour la reprise du travail ce
mercredi était au mans également le jour
de l'arbre noël du comité d'entreprise
jacques cardoze nathalie gallet il a
fallu attendre vingt jours pour qu'il se
retrouve peut-être le signe d'une fin de
conflit grévistes et non-grévistes
ensemble sous un même chapiteau pour un
arbre de noël celui des enfants des
cheminots là en fait pas de différence
je pense que les grévistes savent ce
qu'ils font des gens qui ne font pas
grève
ils ont droit j'ai dialogué mocratie
donc on n'a pas à juger les gens ici
s'il faudra des jours difficiles pour
autant d'oublier la grève le temps d'un
spectacle
difficile aussi d'oublier le malaise de
certains des cadres notamment le fait de
venir au milieu d'agents qui sont en
grève depuis maintenant une vingtaine de
non
ça peut
non pas à présenter je dire une certaine
forme de provocation mais je souhaitais
venir ne serait ce que pour ma fille est
encore en âge de participer aux
festivités du cn car cette grève aura
permis aux cheminots de se rendre plus
disponible pour la première fois ils ont
rejoint leurs enfants à l'occasion de ce
spectacle
parce que c'est un noël un petit peu
particulier a je crois oui bon ben
content d'être là quand même parce que
ça permet de retrouver sa poche milova
les promus par je sais pas si mon
frontières géant ce midi la distribution
de cadeaux c'est fait pour les enfants
de grévistes et de non-grévistes le 20e
jour de grève au mans a bien été marquée
par un arbre de noël non par une
assemblée générale peut-être le signe
d'une détermination moins important